via
ora che stella di merda che ho fatto è
una stella resta non sono capaci almeno
10 a spese rifarci a rimbalzo 39 perciò
mai riparato valente tipo cosa può fare
la bacchetta la già la rete pena ma
perché non sono capace a fare le stelle
facciamo un fiore o bella a tutti i
ragazzi bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono parigi fa vj questo
e per le donne a me la patata grazie
grazie
ma da che triste st whiteboard ogni
volta cioè ciao ragazzi siamo fatti
bella estate bellissimo iniziare live
così come i mongoloidi come state gente
tutto a posto
oggi sono siamo qui va a terra sono qua
con un mio amico che adesso
dall'inquadratura perchè anche lui è
molto bello questo è stato l'arrivo
spostarmi in avanti di spostare tutto
dover cambiare più di tecnici disposti
ciao a tali bene nelle foto è logico c'è
anche da the go che mi aiuterà a today
nella live di oggi e leggera napoli
vostri commenti anche perché abbiamo
messo le le donazioni e quindi mi dà una
mano a leggere i messaggi che sono
levate le donazioni comunque sia oggi
finiamo it nightmares che eravamo
arrivati a metà gioco più o meno e
niente quindi oggi lo finiamo il 2 in 2
like siamo riusciti a venir siamo riusci
io già parlo come sala fitness alessi
abilità ma non ho finito un cazzo però
vabbè ciao persone aspettiamo che si che
vi connettete in un pochettino e poi e
poi si parte verbali
e vero siamo tutti non è sì comunque
sono partita precisamente alle 4
all'aire sono più preciso con le live
che quando andavo a scuola che cazzo
stai facendo
finiremo questo disegnando abbassate 70
parte grazie
stavo scherzando quando ti ha detto che
poteva venire nella laica puoi tornare a
casa volendo da lei cucina linda se un
gran figo fa abitiamo grazie grazie
linda ti amo anch'io se proprio bella io
per quantificano in pace apriti quando
fate delle donazioni compare la mia
immagine in alto a destra che ballo e il
vostro messaggio di sotto come quello
che ho appena letto
e poi c'è più ti fai di sottofondo che
dice va a tutti i ragazzi bellissimo top
è fantastico raga comunque dai sono sono
preso questa roba divise glielo farà una
legge sono dei disegni personalmente
sono troppo bravo ragazzo
ce ne dispiace e aspetta altro si è
sentita una volta sola per altri ragazzi
ho mille volte sai che entra in loop una
poche boom d'altro assi contri me
l'hanno chiesto leggo anche qua che
madonna di dio
cos'è sta roba sono linda che mi ha
detto che sono un gran figo adesso mi sa
che no grazie apprezzo ma no mi sa che
non è più così mi avete chiesto cos'era
questo che ho bruciato la live su su
instagram questa roba è un must e un
massaggiatore terapeutico per la testa
per oggi loro ho sentito quello che su
amazon
lanciano al massaggiatore terapeutico
per la testa cioè tu lo vedi qua e poi
il presidente cazzo è bellissimo dai
debiti utile vieni a farmi un po così
male dai dai dai grigi in questa cosa
grazie qualcosa si può
ahia se non si può mai anno fa malissimo
il file del pd una ragazza madama a me
ne vado via
in questo è uno spazio piccolo penso
come ti senti oppresso in questo momento
è un massaggia testa sarebbe fantastico
la caccia non so chi cazzo è di
lamentato donati che mi compro i
massaggi a testa prevale che c'è una
lettera di capelli che rimane incastra
bellissima st rota lo so lo tengo che
faccio tipo bene velino grazie veli e è
stata l'acquisto migliore dell'ultimo
mese credo capelli a parte e allora
ragazzi io prima di cominciare glieli
solo di fare un termine delle farmacie
one secolo faccio una lista graham sori
dove dico che sono il laico si è prima
riposano e voi che state guardando la
live in questo momento siete i primi a
vedere la lista grande storia quindi la
vedete in diretta allora come l'altra
volta alla fine quindi voi avete la
l'esclusiva con è che capelli in mesh
raga oggi avete visto veramente i
capelli più brutti della vita adesso c'è
gli stai anche c al filtro no alla
giunta i filtri di instagram migliorano
bisogno di filtri faccio schifo anche
così ok allora facciamo
come si fa a dio guarda guarda ora si
dimette il filtro anche se riprende il
tutto schermo ma dalla bellissima sta
roba
a me per sordi ciao a tutti che sono
giulio cesare siamo in diretta sul
canale di youtube quindi connettetevi
ospiti i buffi e chi era in diretta
aveva visto questa cosa prima di poi
buffon mi ha messo una parola tramite lo
schermo bellissimo e bellissimo che vede
la corona mentre tramite lo schermo
vabbè metto la storia ma dai ragazzi
siamo ok davis macchina faccia vedere il
mio ragazzo non fa perché dobbiamo
seguire le mode e tribali e seguono le
mode che sono le 16 06 tendiamo 2
minutes e andiamo siete pronti per il
finale di rittal nightmares io sì anche
perché ho aspettato quattro giorni per
non poter giocato ieri mai teschi piedi
devo fare la live stavo fatta oggi
perché ieri volevo mettere in segreto
edotti manoscritto ferri ma dove il fix
difficimente casi che gli ha l'hiv non
mi dimetto da cyber fino a un certo
punto ma non fino a sto punto cioè non è
che mi hanno dimenticato mettere in
segreto era più figo in segreto quel
giorno
poi oggi più [ __ ] la live così ogni
tanto ciò questi cambi di idee
momentanei che dici possono iniziare ma
vi crea con un pochino con colla
whiteboard siamo insieme siamo amico mio
passami il joystick che faccio le cose
fatte giuste e due giorni è la ragione
che vedrai massei [ __ ] il joystick
oddio che cosa avviato bandai namco ho
sbagliato gioco e della bandai namco
litl nightmares io non lo sapevo mai una
vita la mia viva la vida è sto cazzo di
joystiq cos'è sta roba
grazie
come si gentile
a lei si srotola regata è bello in mente
qui
allora siccome io sì sui giochi sono una
pippa da meno fortuna a mano
[Musica]
per la bella tutti i ragazzi dimmi cosa
è nei geni che cosa mi scrivono il
sabato a un esame i marchi ciò a marghe
buona fortuna per l'esame e scherzi
molto più brava di me è sempre preparati
all'esame per studiare esiste questo che
ti massaggia la testa e ti dà una mano
incredibile però ha detto che se non lo
basso è colpa tua se non la base è colpa
mia e me lo infilo tu sei dove per
punizione
il brand di the nightmare riprendi
partita male vista la prima light una
parte si da parte sino l'ha seguita
tutta lui perché è un buffo questo
serviva tutto ha promesso che sta
seguirai tutto anch'io che non esci di
qua c'è la porta e qua ci sono di mezzo
lui piuttosto mori se provi uscire
questa roba definisce tu sai dove anche
perché molte volte io sto gioco sugo
quindi levi da me molto ma una mano
anche grossa
allora ragazzi erano rimasti che c'è un
amica strati qua sotto e praticamente
oddio sono un mimo che figata però in
casa di questo tipo di teramo
avevamo ucciso il tizio che tentava di
non mi ricordo i comandi non ci si
abbassa ok ucciso il tizio che tentava
di prenderci cioè non so neanche come ho
fatto a ucciderlo gli ho staccato le
braccia non so solo io come ho fatto
niente siamo nel condotte dobbiamo
andare
dobbiamo andare avanti comunque
dall'altra magistro gioco ho capito che
sta bambina fa parte di un sono salsicce
questo è un gioco per vegani questo i
buy vegani non riescono ad aggrapparmi
che cos'è sta roba
ecco questo sito dopo la live grazie a
questo prezzo non volevo neanche fare
che è stato adesso facendo bene mi hanno
pescato che storia perché guardi c'è
attaccata una scarpa ali questa roba usa
così ecco il tipo cosa pitcher eccoti
manuale e ucciso
ce ne sono altri che figata figata bene
proprio cosa un deposito di cadaveri
possano salami giganti o sono cadaveri
non ho capito io ho sempre fame ci ho
visto cagando addosso sempre fame non ho
mai capito sta roba qua sempre fame al
maggio di cinque minuti è peggio di me
poi non ingrassa come me è uguale
identico un topo maggio un topo di vita
se devo continuare a giocare una roba
dove ogni tre secondi si piega la pancia
dallo stop ho detto di si lega la pancia
dallo store coin volevo dire li spiega
lo stomaco dalla fame e non so proprio
tempo starò per il legno il mio italiano
nelle live
questo non lo devo toccare scommette
però io sono tutto jolo era già scattata
la trappola che però anche io volendo a
mali estremi estremi rimedi
o mi mangio accendino mi mangio intoppi
è la madonna quanta fame ciò o rimasti
castrato no che schifo loro maggiore
davvero dai un posto pasta roba vegani
che state guardando questa live
non guardate questa live a prescindere
ma già mangiato è bella un cazzo
che schifo è sempre mangiato dopo il
live mangio dopo il live è finita male
andrea che dona mi dice che i romani a
due verifiche due interrogazioni che se
vanno male colpa tua
andrea che ad verifica interrogazioni
domani grazie della donazione è se va
male e di tortura come dopo finisce
malissimo così ragazzi odioso come che
guardate che divido con dovete fare le
interrogazioni e le verifiche anche io
facevo così guarda vini video mentre
devo fare
durante le interrogazioni interrogazione
finita male secondando rai qual è il
problema
cioè io non ho capito se questa è una
nave perché poi non mi sono poi perché
poi i sì quattro giorni non vi dico
quanta gente ha tentato di scuole ranni
finale visto gioco ma io che sono più
forte non mi sono fatto spoilerare
niente e quindi non ho capito nulla di
quello che è successo ancora il sì
quattro giorni non mi sono fatto sperare
niente sono troppo gravi come come 13
anche per non farmi spoilerare 13 è
stato un casino
grazie fatto gentile tanto confini tanto
si sapeva mai all'inizio si sapeva
infatti io non abbia mai visto
poi c'è del sangue quindi è passata una
tipa con le mestruazioni quanto te l'ho
fatta stata tutta un fa più ridere c'è
una tipa con le mestruazioni ridete
grazie degli iscritti
potevi entrare
cazzo sta succedendo qua che si muovono
da soli perché dovresti mettere un
carrello con delle ruote in una cosa che
continua a fare così una nave
possibilmente cioè dei deficienti vv
settete se sta roba
e non posso spingerlo perché ha forse se
si fossero video vi aspetta aspetta
spingo che meglio io spingo tiro pensava
davvero la patente che tragedia ma non
c'è un modo per salire perché poi non ci
posso salire non ci arrivo 44 la
schiaccia voci arriva salve mac un
hamburger merckel chris lee macbeth con
piazza la cucina di ratatouille besta
sento uno che che sma cella sicuramente
eco arca [ __ ] carlo cracco masterchef
in diretta ragazzi ora che bello quello
che bella faccia che ci salva
noi non sono come non solo commestibile
io porto a totana va preso non dovevo
fare noi
ami cucina proprio e bastardo bastardo
cos'è non vale neanche una un dito di
cannavacciuolo non è il gran giorno ma
che la mangia da questa strategia in
fila ma che mangia capisce cazzo tu noi
infilarli al punto 6 dove senta signor
camera vuole vuole un po di carota elisa
dove che si sta avvicinando
non sta facendo sempre comunque piatti
migliori di quelli che cucino io molto
migliore ora come felice ora che faccia
soddisfatta che c'è ma perché ci sono
degli uomini che sono fatto non mi vedo
non mi vede tanto stupido schifano per
rimanere qui ha dimenticato che
effettivamente lui può venire anche di
qua o montana sono un deficiente ed ha
visto che la porta pensavo di potermi
infilare lì sotto niente non sarà capace
scusatemi sono stupido per ora ve lo
sapevate già bella a tutti il ragazzo
bella bella testa studiando stai
studiando anatomia veterinaria è questo
che mi l'anatomia visto tizio qualcuno
su ca veloce la cena celo celo celo celo
celo gelosissimo no dai raga però ma è
l'annunciata perché [ __ ] adesso fa
il giro è un filo passato toscanelli
aspettando
e stupido
madonna fatto l'ha preso nel culo ben
peggiore la carota chi è che sta
segnando anatomia di irene grazie irene
che studia nato mia così almeno capisci
perché continua a mangiare e sono magro
sarà colpa del fato avviamento tutto
intelligenza e cervello incazzo leader
grazie da donation
comunque poi cucina uscieri nani doppia
visto rai della vita non mi ha visto che
con uno share del business ti giochi che
fa veramente vomitare comunque madonna
sembra mia nonna quando cucinava i
tortellini ai tempi dagli gnocchi voce
la mia norme caldo ciao papà oggi fai i
geni cucina il sushi
mi sa che non devo stare questo senso
devo trovare una chiave perché lo trova
una chiave dovunque vado qual è il
problema
dove sta chiave maledetta si tifosa
questi l'elevetico le lanterne là sopra
io accendo sempre vigliacca se ormai
scoperto cosa minchia servono perché non
ti sa dalla partita trova in essere da
un bene a possa andare corso perché culo
ok proprio prima tranche che tanto paga
lui vedi argento sta però ha mai capito
che da far bene
posso andare qua sopra sì lo trovarono a
chiave raga non so dove sia non ne
vadano in minima idea ho la più pallida
di qua magari no perché non mi attacco
al pescespada mi attacco al bene con lo
sta vomitando vi schifo lo faccio una
delle in testa c'è una vita di merda via
mia vita è prodotta mira che ciò a raga
che brutta mira che ciò è niente non
sono capaci faccia veramente bene
ora ci sarà staccata da qualche parte
non so che qui team a scalare le cose
prima o poi troverò qualcosa c'è una c'è
un perché questo team i pesci attaccati
al soffitto ma che problema italia scusa
aveva trovata per la cattura dei ragazzi
successo come successo al piano di
isabella berla c'è un cesso al piano di
sopra non ho capito il perché eleonora
no questo non posso del giornale che
schifo dici che sei bellissimo ma
ammazza grazie alla ragazza sei
bellissima mica come questo qua questa
qua
anzi io mi paragono un po questa cosa
qua in mano però apprezzo sempre i
complimenti anche quelli falsi canidata
non sa niente di verres precedente
perché questo tiene un cesso sopra la
cucina ma quanto igienico s'ostina ridi
mergoni nuovo era sentita ragazzi dovete
spiegare io adesso non vado avanti sto
gioco ficano non trovo un nano che vi
parlai mi diceva sono un nano schifoso
cerca di capire che la mia presenza
inutile in sto gioco
mi sa che c'è uno che dorme non avevo
visto prima però che la chiave la chiave
anti che devo jobs in concentrazione se
prendo la chiave potrei averne il culo
però secondo ce la posso fare questa
cosa finirà malissimo rega tra chi è al
4 con un cesso attaccato al muro
prendi le scappa è non correre una
scelta ha sbagliato ma ciao zio e vado
via grazie e stato bello conoscerti
porca [ __ ] non mi prende dello scazzo
ed efficiente major è quanto tempo già
facendo la roma della vita lavoro
derivato sulle scale l'arrivo del
plateau sulle scale in deficit ragazzi
ce la faccio ragazza a basso carico
vernice la zucca è perché ho sbagliato
ho mollato la chiave subito però è
difficile perché devo trovare un modo
per di riguardo se magari stonano mi
desse una mano invece di scappare ma da
una moto mi stanno sul culo signori
schifosi maledette non posso tipo
provare a distrarlo prima così prendo la
chiave che già sveglio
non se ne starà facendo scesi nella
ragazzi sono un deficiente tracciato
tutto
beh non mi ha visto il merito chic non
ha visto brutto forte quando come quando
mi sveglio la mattina è andato via ride
messaggio allora lisa decide di sposarla
ciao lisa ti sposo fammi finire qualche
devo film province resta roba ne va
della mia autostima
grazie misa della donation luca invece
su dovuto dopo della classe per guardato
laico e che è stato buttato fuori la
classe perché ho dalla mia live che si
procurò capisce un cazzo
e invece è rinchiusa questo punto per
mentre studio questo to music come
sottofondo mentre studi amy tutto quello
che impara e negativo era stata
l'interrogazione dice sono bella tutti i
ragazzi e basterà si capisce più niente
che io non sono andata al sicuro qua in
questo momento è perché sto tenendo per
di tipo andato esattamente dove devo
andare io casinò in bagno essere accesso
che vacilla mi chiedo dove dark
agganciava schifo il guido vederlo che
cala agility raiganj della liuc
questo ti offre un caffè da grazie dio
grazie le coffe io però prendo solo
quello macchiato perché ci sono ancora
piccolo perché io invece di aprire le
porte le chiudo per che cosa c'è in
questo cervello che non funziona mai che
non capisco neanche io a fissa poi
domandato il tipo non lo vogliamo sapere
ragazzi dove andato tipo non lo vogliamo
sapere quindi via cioè avviene non era
neanche accesso perché scusami hanno due
sessi attaccati qual è il problema è
perché tu non ti ascolto grazie
francesco non leggo i tuoi messaggi di
farla donazione da si apre era aperto
prima perché la si apre no regala devo
andare da un'altra parte
no mica adesso al di tornare giù bello
bello e 2 vado che ne so aspettare se
vuoi anche una faccia da capo però
vincolate fanno accendere la candela che
sicuramente un check point che non
funziona per ora no raga e non posso
tornare di qua ora che bello vuoi quadro
non posso tornare di qua devo accendere
devo trovare altra via sulla volta sola
e ho capito però non posso entrare alla
porta va bene a chiave lasciamo quanto
non sia per nulla adesso c'è una leva
che non avevo visto prima era troppo
impegnato a scappare ma il tipo dove è
andato e tutto questo secondo me
l'ascensore mi porta giù e quindi io
porto anche la chiave poi boh magari mi
sbaglio però per non saper né leggere né
scrivere
questi qui non stanno veramente arredare
le case non ha niente di più ma si
riporta a giugno il portale ora quindi
possiamo tornare in cucina ignavi del
cazzo te pareva bella addio
lorenzo
i miei studi mi posso parlare l'italiano
non so parlare l'italiano music come
sottofondo per storia zio grazie a un
futuro si studierà la storia di fa vj
quindi non ci saranno anche bisogno di
farlo come che si chiama che è fatto
strada
lorenzo lorenzo pensavo che mi chiamassi
ma vi pare che diavolo re insomma che ne
so io volevo chiamare al signor rustu
grazie ciao valenza di un bel 9 comunque
come ci arrivo non so senti craco
no non ha visto non ci posso credere se
poi rincarato il nostro mary cazzo
ho capito se mi segue sono in cui forse
grazie successo che forse era
un'anomalia sono riuscito a picchiare
l'unico ma cristo gioco barrate raga non
mi ha visto e mi sanno c'è spero che non
so se mi ha visto dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai che ha fatto ciò che ho
fatto ce l'abbiamo fatta
ce l'ha fatta una vita e mezza per
questa porta farti amare un vicolo cieco
scommetti e muoio drasticamente
comunque sono tagliato un pochettino me
lo vedo carico come tanto che si dice la
legge ah sì ma che a pagare i brand sei
grande e servito per mettere una
guardare
grazie ma dimmi chi mette i messaggi
sono arrivati a a brian non sento il
nome non sentono a brian tu hai un nome
decisamente figo lo posso usare il
machete per cavalli la faccia ai
testicoli ammesso che ce li abbiano di
prima porta comunque ci sono machete e
salsicce ovunque questa cosa ancora da
capire inclinati [ __ ] barca una vera
qualsiasi cosa tu sia non apro la porta
se no varcava che non ci passa la sua è
chiuso è chiuso giorno parlato bene è
chiuso cavolo è chiuso
era chiusissimo proprio non sono entrato
ha manco per sbaglio la c'è un coso dove
cede 5 entra e sicuro qua è pieno di
salsicce non mette neanche troppo
affanno in studio in realtà comunque qua
come il minimo appena attivo il
tritacarne arriva anche arrivato dalla
troupe di masterchef ma cucino io faccio
io faccio faccio io per l'agenzia bella
più di
ma dico io ti ricordo apple grazie al
giusto quei 200 punti di consente
intellettivo in meno però ganz quanto
bisogna trattarla la carne per tanto è
altissimo ma che vista il pollice che
della pietà vostra finito la mazza
tirchi volte sì perché cazzo mi sapete
ritar la carne spiegami e non ai allora
perché non mettono le leve così allora
non lo so finiscila ma basta un'ora e
mezza il tritone soprattutto il pane per
i perché non gli ordini non solo da
justin non c'ho voglia di cucinare
neanche dei giochi dai che palle che ne
so io cosa vuole cento passi ragazzi no
scherzavo
anche perché quella parte sbarrata non
potrai nessuno ma che devo tirare il suo
pieno titolo
ma non sarebbero così casa vince da sei
giorni ma basta il market rito fatte
quando parli chi si sente bene ma se tu
ti senti
sennò avvicinati c'è un problema d'ayala
immutata pirla ragazzo che cazzo da fare
sono sincero amico entrare semplicemente
lì dentro forse anche perché la donna
non vedo l'utilità di sta roba
ok a dover solo entrare cuamm il tema
che se tu in ora che dice che devo
tritare pezzo di carne non mettiamo
dentro avrò tritto dopo sono nel banco
frigo
non so come funziona e un banco frigo
però non di sicuro non è il modo più
economico per far funzionare anche
questo un collezionabile alla fine
ragazze scoperto non servono una sega
prove a parte romperli non lo sapevo
sapete solo 3 non hanno ancora successo
va beh devo scassare qualcosa nel banco
frigo sicuro per fare arrivare il tizio
scopetti secondo posto ma anche perché
io dovrei fare arrivare un tizio lo so
solo io
ma ci passo io qua bravo che batte juan
ma cosa si arriva solo applicarmi quadri
profondità e sti giochi di fonte un
sacco non capisco mai e quando devo
andare in fondo
maya
ad aggrapparmi
ma direttamente
appunto e zio ha capito
non posso andare allenamento la muoio
ritrita
sarei curioso di vedere come voglio
sulla ventola per tutti
ma non me lo fa fare paolo ma guarda
cielo gnomo vedi che non hanno neanche
il pisello stico così riproducono la
ragazza che studiava anatomia di prima
che dice amnesty prono con ignoti
è una cagata il cazzo però funziona non
funziona che lo fai qua
in quella piazza
questa roba e non ci si arrampica
bene
no non posso se non avete visto quanto è
dio
[Musica]
dai fan venire bella niente non devo
fare un cazzo
anche qua a viti che qua c'è la roba per
buttare giù la carne vedi che doveva
buttare giù la carne alla fine è vero io
non avevo capita sta roba
non ho capito cosa serve quella stanza
sinceramente provo a far perder tempo
secco no il filetto un po di pepe verde
questo è cucino io ragazzi che mostrano
anna piangere dalla gioia poetico
l'intossicazione alimentare concreto
metodo il viste cose per non saper né
leggere né scrivere
leo mentre qualcos'altro c'è un dato di
sé che bastano o se questa nutrita
ragazzi così diventato macellaio
simulator cambiato gioco luca omicidi
iscritti grazie luca che mi seguì dai
primi 100 iscritti non mi sarei seguito
neanche mai io stesso dai primi 100
iscritti
urlavo come un orgasmo di quelli che
sono forti le risulta maggiorato
ma già dai grazie luca della da nation
tutta un'altra con due un'altra sotto
vita era sempre medica 4x2 ma con la
stessa frase a grazie a chi ricorda due
volte nello di due note quindi a me
ricordi ok ho capito è che sì che
nascono i bambini
e così che nascono i vaneggiato equidi
io mi attaccò la salsiccia gioco
dell'anno della vita gioco della vita
outlast è una merda non avete capito
inside era una merda questo è un gioco
non quella roba lì non avete capito
niente
ma da è mica geniale c'era destinati io
prendo le salsicce le attacco al
soffitto e faccio tazza di nudo in casa
sono per replicare questo voglio vedere
i costi di sta roba in giro con le
salsicce grazie ne avete capito c'è il
geniale comunque sono queste menti nel
banco frigo e io questo mente con la
felpa c'è un caldo ea metà bassa le mie
lo invidio troppo da coprire no basta se
chiave è tratto il pene marcelo gol
cioè ho capito non ci arrivo e poi ha
chiamato caso chiamato litro non ho
centrato mare borgo
ho mai visto non ha visto non ha visto
non ha visto il marito l'ha visto dove
sarà dov'è dove però prendiamo per il
culo poi mi venne natale no non l'ha
vista lo so
la chiave sarà sopra nell'ascensore col
minimo sono stai infilando vi va bene
così sarà del formaggio sicuramente
fresco
presso sala ha preso stamattina in
discarica
vedendo come fatto con la pelle che la
pelle che già adesso ci hanno messo di
chi l'altro fuori lentamente ad alcuno
ai faccio casino o merda e non posso
andare giù ai simpson da regioni di
averlo per un attimo ha avuto l'inferno
negli occhi perché c era il catino apre
che tipo sia accorto che ho preso
l'ascensore si accorto che ho preso
l'ascensore caso è qua dentro subito
aspettare voglio vederlo che arriva e
non riesce a prendermi
ops ops mi dispiace mi dispiace troppo
veramente cura in tutto il lardo cela
nelle guance se non sul collo capisco
questa maurizio costanzo maria apre la
bontà varie ha fatto e non mi ha visto
che non ho mai scusa le bisogna fare qua
speriamo non sa che devo fare piano e
dice se passo davanti mi vede ma perché
sono caduto su protesi guardato bene
dove dove la chiave ma ti rendi conto
della malattia di questi ma come faccio
ma a parte come la prendo ma cosa che in
una chiave sul banco da macello
guardavo questa chiave mettiamo laddove
cucino schifo proposto scrivo questo ci
resta è stata o no stando random col
dito lo stesso detto che si metterà in
culo
volevamo dire tirarlo fuori non vi
conviene far casino è far sì che egli
segue
aveva tanti come stanno
madonna cosa ho fatto ma mi lasci si
concentrano è zio di correnti ricorda il
giro di cose perché si non con madonna
posso fatto con saw iv l'azione della
vita dov'era la roba bo vigile ma come
farà sentire il mio peso l'ascensore
pesaro un grammo e la chiama alla chiave
settimane si è incazzato
devo aprire la porta anche abbastanza
velocemente prima che l'ascensore torni
su meraviglioso veloce zio per devi fare
veloce zio di farvelo ascensione zio di
aprile però c'è bravo dove penso che
fino aiuto ap sotto mica male che c'era
poi era bucato
che gli appelli che già come minimo sono
il condimento degli spaghetti doveva va
bene parlate che non torna indietro più
equa deve andare esattamente dove vado
io è che può star tranquilla si chiude
qui posso entrare laden si sa non è
stata una grande idea considerando che
c'e la pattumiera della vita qua però
hanno trovato una storia lavandini siamo
a posto
hai visto che tu cosa sei beccato di
nuovo poco per la stavolta comunque
validi prima era geniale della
bellissima spera da traffico
l'articolo parla aggiunti i ragazzi ciao
zio 4 balzo che una sentenza quindi una
barzelletta varie iniziative pensate
io sono scappata ai luoghi e noi di più
le barzellette el'ex mancava
dell'ente
non sto pensando ho concentrato a questo
punto sta roba tra i contendenti
facciamo che la dico aspetta che come
quest'anno si sta ponendo il pavimento
abbiamo risparmiano sul sapone per il
pavimento minuto stanno facendo
bella argentina che bella aspetta mica
bambino nella caricatura mente o ancora
che la barzelletta
aspetta aspetta aspettati una
barzelletta che io riuscirò a finire
questo gioco senza morire anche una
volta perché fa ridere funziona
piatti rotti per terra coi piedi nudi un
deficiente deficiente deficiente è una
barca vacca schifosa sono i piatti per
del carlino korengal dato che speights
piano applicare alle scatole diceva è
tornato perché ha detto che a un 28
detto che lui ha un bel nome
chi bryan bryan amber nome si è piazzato
e per l'italia mentre metà segretamente
in italia abilitati grettamente come
nomen omen un hardware è segretamente
riuscisse a finire sotto come basta
moglie greta menti lo sa fare questo è
il saluto che la svizzera grazie trio
della svizzera
ora che sono insaponato calcio pulito e
quello non e sapone fa schiuma ma non
essa non è un sapone
cosa vuol fare qualcosa ho attivato con
però barico tirato una leva ha capito
così servita con la leva che non ha
spiegato
sicuramente non credo torna dietro a
levarlo tirata quindi la propria ho
attivato qualcosa che non ho capito come
posso nascondermi anche nella schiuma le
figaro magari non faccio capisco i
piatti odio
la donna che k siamo questi sono i
lavapiatti e vedevo farek lining sui
piatti scommette no perché non sa
[Musica]
ma visto
questa parte di fitch e racca perché
sono in due
capito non è che sono in due
un casino
se non avessimo questo di fermo e voleva
salute
ok
sto cercando di capire come arrivare di
sopra allora i piatti per i piatti non
mi fanno arrivare
siccome non e quei piatti
funziona
mamma mia
alcol kaiser madonna era cosa messo male
dove vuoi che sia
dove subisce lavori sud di bahia carne
no dai però deve farmi cazzi vostri
legali come non ancora provata
dall'altra parte quindi faccio giro
posto sì però ragazze non sapete a vari
piatti dovete aprire anche per te e
dovete pulire anche per terra non lo
fate
io ho attivato qualcosa che non ho
ancora capito cosa però quelli store
avanti per terra dei geni questi
ma c'era una porta ma forse devo
semplicemente tornare indietro sai
perché ho attivato una roba da stephanie
scalare sarà l'arena borsa di ghiaccio i
nerd e rispettati
madonna
cioè
ecco proprio
porta di là però nicchia cioè mi sono
fatto tutto il corteo che hanno visto da
bestie casi tanto ci arrivano luca
riporta aggancio non so se mi porta qui
e basta tiro un cristone e che lamentava
la sua che valga meno ai fatti che va a
porta avanti
ciao zio ed è proprio lì può aprire la
porta quindi c'è un buon e curatoriale
quanto sono incazzati quando io con la
leva stimato i ganci è capito che era
una novità da parte primo bella ciao ma
preso frate hanno preso abbia fatto
ripartiti qualche contratto un ragazzo e
vabbè un niet cioccio ci stavo riuscendo
al primo tentativo ma ragazzi
dai una [ __ ] quasi allora il secondo è
quello che io mentre lines campo
risponde ai messaggi sono capace di fare
anche questa allora c'è maria che ha
condannato a morte perché questa scala
verona 600 ucciso dalla madre e il pd
non sei capace mantovano insieme stessa
di stata capace rozes
perché ti deve uccidere tua mamma perché
guardiamo a quanto la carta per mangiare
così ma dai non fatelo solo se ce
l'avete non è che non è necessario farla
partecipe della striscia grazie comunque
però non c'era necessario perché quando
ha fatto non solo se avete poi la calma
porca [ __ ] ma mentre girano le palle
ti giuro non riesco a fare una roba
stupida lo so agganciarmi non riesco ad
agganciare un deficiente che non sono un
deficiente
ok come faccio a non riuscire spiegami
quale salirà poi mi chiama lanciato la
bottiglia facciamo abbastà ciò cartaceo
fatta finché credito e l'altra messaggio
circolato mangio che ti ricorda la
barzelletta che non c'entri con il gioco
una barzelletta che non c'entra col
gioco ma quante cose basta hanno rotto
le palle
mi sono rotto di morire al cugino marta
guarda come se la gode
per questa parte in porta di una valenza
schifosa maledetta gli alimenti più che
di religione tutto questo da tempo 1
tempo tempo io adesso tempo fa adesso
tempo ottana
siamo fatta morire prima non ero neanche
una sola moto e dovremo aspettare quello
per farlo devo entrare nel tubo non
c'entro nel tumore ma io non mi stacco
neanche il cazzo vista cabaret scusami
nazista caso diano di carlo addosso ma
anche stessi facendo io sarò e la
profondità visto gioco che mi prende
velico vediamo abbiamo finito un
capitolo pisa la cucina dio esiste no
grazie
no ho un attimo un attimo regala un
secondo di basa che vi giuro sto sudando
sudando ma perché c'è sempre lo scratch
e guarda sempre rimane sempre che poi
era meglio dei miei capelli guardaroba
anche donne della famiglia non secondo
la è un secondo che sto veramente ci
sono pezzato sono pezzato porca vacca
vai a cercare sul sito di barzellette
così diciamo bella nostri ragazzi ciao
vale saluti dall'unica trentenne che ti
segue non sei l'unica credibile
credo spero non sia così non è così
credi ti conosco trentini che visse da è
molto raro è molto raro però ci son o
sto facendo mi sta procurando un orgasmo
da solo provare anche puoi provare voi
che figo è noia figo giuro ma criminali
dopo minchia raja
e stata cosa è veramente stato un ansia
sto gioco che non avete idea incredibile
metterà l'inter ansia gesù quanto siamo
47 me ma date forse sono cinque
paragrafi sei non quattro in totale sono
abbiamo fatti tre ok all'inizio del
gioco dico siete ripartiamo dai comunque
puma quale sponsor c'è semplicemente già
avevo questo ammette non mi sta su sta
vagliando il nostro lago e smaliziati un
film porno basta dal gioca a gesù ti
giuro sto pensando si vede
cos'è sta roba ma dove siamo qualcuno me
lo spiega a siamo usciti forse ma lo
scopo scorsa se mi aspetto di pisa che
il mistero buffo il contrario
lo sono per scappare filmato
lo scopo è scappare credo anche perché
c'è gente vivo l'ammazzare quindi se non
è scappare e fare il deficente io
capisco porre capire chi è stati va però
c'è un letto che è stata spedita in
questo posto nella valigia quella dove
abbiamo
la gente sta bambina e una bambina alla
fine non è un uomo non è un trentenne
pesare sul trentenne l'anno
è la bambina che è stata spedita in
questo posto tramite una valigia e si
risveglia in questo posto quindi vincere
il gioco dove aspetta la valigia e poi
scappare però non ho capito perchè
l'hanno mandata
cos'è questo punto
chi è sta gente [ __ ] non si capisce
bene di chi erano nave lo vedi che c'e
ora giovane siamo fuori
ora che siamo usciti era una nave sto
schifo lo sapevo io che non avevano
destra e altre
e 9000 enorme miglia quanto è grossa
porca vacca e gigantesco da vinci che il
gigantesco
[Musica]
quale 87
la donna una trentenne donna
il complesso nel senso dice loro donna
trentenne siamo meno lo capisco no c'è
un valore 87 censite in tante donne
trentenni che state guardando questo
video grazie così notte trentenni che si
scoprono in questo momento da quando la
da quando normale la scritta prima tutte
trentenni
immagini di prospettiva non è quella che
gli fanno sole le donne entro in termini
il contrario
guarda guarda signor la signora che per
cappello diciamo dalla signora cos'è la
signora lui e malizia fatto per quello
di dalla signora aiutata dal vestibolo a
un prestito spettatori sono rientrato
nella nave un [ __ ] ci sono arrivato
per fuggire sono rientro attenti però mi
sa che devo rientrare per forza perché
non ha senso
ok dunque abbiamo scoperto che siamo in
una bene l'importante la scoprire che
era ok
no perché non soccorrere sui tubi certo
prova a vincere superfici curve io non
capisco in modo in palla per me mi
appaga il cervello capisco non soccorre
esito fidget spinner di me non cadaveri
perciò dei problemi sostituti madonna
c'è veramente incredibile mi sembra la
puntata quella di vita personale ama la
città incantata di miyazaki con dentro
tutti dentro contro la halep hermann
guardo tibelli trattati
buona tipo intanto de a sinistra da
sinistra ma scompare ogni tanto quella è
l'unico l'unica informa gli altri sono
andati un po alla pizza maniera media
grazie a questo gioco si corre anche che
figata
questa è la parte superiore della nave
che è abbastanza decente rispetto alla
svolta possa sembrare le porte a questo
e cibo queste sono torte possono seconda
fine la torta dei denti dentro la torre
che ci ho proprio voglia di torta d
ma di quella vuole farmi al latte dentro
da zio
ebbene questi l'amica mi attacca il
ciclo case prega ama questo romagnano
proteste di culo
magnate bagnate il cuore che se chi
cazzo voi cosa sta succedendo
quanta fame quest'uomo date il dati a un
olio che imita quest'uomo quanto già fa
adesso cristiano qui vai via via via via
non ha preso ancora massa 4 corner oddio
qualche casino fa come questo non scappi
miglia tutto il tavolo schermo non ci
arriva non basta perché il grasso devo
saltare sulla pizza ha dato compatta
mangiare non è occupata a mangiare
ancora la forza di calcio francese barca
non mi fai parlare inizia beh ma tanto
ancora c'è quindi questa ditemi se non è
la parte migliore del gioco c'è un tipo
che casca aperta e mi segue striscia
casini ha detto mi vede uguale quando si
vede non mi sente mi vede è per forza
hanno fatto altro che questa parte chi
volete siano stati va da sola io quando
vedo la modella ragazze è comunque la
tipa anni vede come passo sopra i piatti
sopra i piatti ho capito ho capito a
decade questo non ci arriva è stato
sulla leva
non ci arrivo sono caduto sulla morte lo
sapevo sapevo e continua mangiarlo ha
detto vabbè lasciamo stai va bene questo
è troppo discontinuo il cotechino è la
tua bottiglia che si torni bisogno
quale salto sulla faccia a faccia sul
lato
racconti si arriva a milano
dove non ce lo hai lasciando alla sega
avery adesso capita è però non ci aveva
dunque sembra la mia prof
musica delle superiori te lo giuro
capitolo appendere sulla salsiccia gioco
dell'anno è questa questo è il
ristorante andiamo a mangiare al
ristorante così stasera purissimi a
mangiare gli gnocchi si è salito su una
salsiccia in qualsiasi stato un fenomeno
spiega mente so perché non so se riesco
sgabello poi al suo partito la salsiccia
non sono scoperto
ansa
cioè venire i no mi ero secolo se
guardate lo so
ma prima però vorrei vedere se le cose
che possono prevedere cosa c'è
una persona volete bulbi voleva pure ali
e per salvarmi sta per accendere la
candela
comunque le candele non sarà più casi
ora dice la minaccia il disegno mio sul
mister
ho una media di scampo su tutto diamo
tutto preso a l'ho preso da marzo a
maggio america merita merita merita
dolore però non d'oro mi hanno sempre
lasciato nel momento del bisogno adesso
io soffro impasto a satana passata alla
fredda vai su voi su come si lanciano
andiamo sul pratico rilancia lo sgancio
ragioniamo lanciate 27 sopra so però il
bastardo
a formulare il tasto
come ho fatto prima ok piace niente
speriamo sbaglia col tasto barrot ha
scritto il fermo al lancio
e tranvata si stava prendendo e non ci
riesco non ci arriva
arrivando lancia proprie colpe dai scemo
vedi che ti l'anti mani in pasta gli
altri e vieni qua a rompermi le bande
come accendere qua capito ma serve
dunque servirà come quando ho capito
cosa cassino sostanza non serve a niente
frega solo per prenderlo il gioco va
bene
niente devo solo prendo solo per
dall'unione di quattro dove vai
allora ragazzi devo trovare l'utilità di
sta roba
comunque io voglio darla veramente in
pasto a qualcuno se lo merita se lo
merita torino nel secchio giochiamo a
lancia vogliamo nel secchio vai a questo
punto era un secchio aperto come manca
la fisica visto gioco o la partita
ha bocciato come dobbiamo veramente
portato che qualche modo sul tavolo
perché se lo porti sul tavolo
per la raggiungere ma vedi ed efficiente
devo sanchez lo passa per prima
[Musica]
no no no no ma non sono stato io ne devo
fare io sto impegnando mi stai bakery
che devono merita di morire
cioè capisce le sottolineato merita
proprio la morte
ma soprattutto pronti quando si tagga
magari riesco a lanciarlo dire vabbè
foraggia travaglia che a lebron james
stai fermo ma non di dio allora che non
c'è verso riesco a spostare lo sgabello
almeno a pd che posso fare lo sgabello
facciamo quindi sicura
non si toglie lo gnomo non riesco a
spostare lo sgabello merita l'amore ma
questa è una volta che devi toglierti da
cazzo diamo di madonna guarda guarda
guarda questo verità ci sei scordato
io che nervoso
se come c'è un tasto per appoggiarlo
salta salta salta mi par di noi si fa
sta partecipando questa perdonanza
ammazzo insomma ti giuro l'on
lo sguardo io uccido la famiglia di don
lo ammazzo la posso farlo senza la
mascotte sega dell'agnola che veramente
interamente sui nervi guarda sempre in
mezzo
che fastidio il vero prova anche lui a
salire sopra ma mica capito la meno che
non debba spingere le scarpe segue
dimmi che mi segue mi fa ridere
questo non chiamo assunto delle droghe
dove sei
[Musica]
lino il chianti via tutto via facendo
senza nice nice
maledetto il carnevale
giampaolo inquinavano non si arriva un
caso mi ha fatto perdere un'ora di tempo
e non serviva un caveri che fa quello
che faccio io
santa e santanchè non un deficiente
perdono un'ora di tempo sacrificarla
stata
tutto in santo
nora
vediamo chi sei
mi spieghi in scena lì sopra lo dici tu
che cela risolvere persone diciamo sì a
puntate sulla bottiglia chissenefrega
dove averne io voglio il tavernello del
tavernello wells del tavernello
era rincasato quello via via via via via
via via gli alieni e via di rieti
beh va beh naturalmente la jones fatto
le cose incredibili regali
siamo nel ristorante ragazzi siamo nella
main sala quello sempre ovviamente che
ci sa fare
non riesco a salire di sopra magari
scoprirlo prima sarebbe stato meglio
sfuggente ceche testata dato che tenga
il salto sopra gli ha dato anche un
achievement sfuggente stata l'isola
pertanto lo sa io però non posso farlo
perché questo correre solo quando ha
voglia possa salire anche 39 volevi
ricaricare la donna madonna ad ormai
lanciato e mi prendessi cura
che culo da vado non potesse che vai
raga ansia
per noi siamo sempre all'angolo da
webcam senso e rispetto verso la mia
parte l'arci le cose dal gip
magari è giusto l'aver kahn dopo cosa
dici tu è giusto dopo la webcam e porca
vacca schifosa deficiente dove vado
corri corri corri corri tornato in
cucina e tutto sto cordella funzionano
gli specchi il suo gioco e tanta roba
provate a scaricarvi nel cesso ma non ha
avuto 88 faccia fai ad abbassarmi andare
là sotto mano complichiamoci la vita
tranquillamente
scommetti che adesso vado nel cesso e
quello mi caga davanti quando vado a
parigi con la vita faccio veramente
scrive ma dio esperto lanciatori le
carta igienica
dedicato a cagare guardino anche
lanciato la carta si guarda in giro non
c'è nessuno eh no a fare di nuovo a fare
nel salotto per terra
guarda che chiede disastri a mettere a
posto io avevo anche se sai che per
l'anno
io può essere un kakà tissimo bella
azione
[Musica]
pensa se ti può mettere cagava e che
controlla kartitsch erica musci da una
parte quello cui scivola sotto tecnico
piero io allora non fare qua disagio
dice weber il figlio grazie ciao alisa
grazie sei tu [ __ ] io sono la lenticchia
ti amo potreste notare giulia alessandra
elisa ed elena java giulia ciao
alessandra ciao elisa e ciò che elena mi
sono ricordato tutti i linguaggi
all'alzheimer fa passi indietro ormai
comunque io non so che cazzo fai il
successo niente turning era solo per
scappare la tipo c'è una ragazza di
famiglia
prendo il barile che ha fatto cadere il
momento quale faccio il mio gradino
fermo qua sopra sa cosa di rowland la
vaniglia
ci ho provato è come faceva prima
maniglia non ci arriva
capito ma allora se questa sinistra
[Musica]
sai cos'è la carta igienica non posso
salito da cappellini no è un corso per
una scala si presta a ce l'ha ma questa
volta bisogna chiamare è una parola
posso spostarmi non so
[Musica]
perché devo pagare il bagno tutto basato
sul sesso o per la gt ragazzi di simone
chiede fare un figlio 0 sul più quello
sì più avanti si forse ora non c'è più
avanti si deve almeno però come ci
arriva la soprano spieghi io dal
sopracitato arrivare uscendo da liquidi
devo sicuro esposto con qualcosa per far
aggiungere ma non è difficile non solo
raggiungere una [ __ ] maniglia non è
che devo fare chissà cosa cara
marigliano il cesso quanto pesante quel
quanto spettante secretati
esatto
[Musica]
porca vacca o ragazze non sono capace
senza scopi lo provava a 90 dire quando
ha confidato in prova per il meta con
qualcosa
il vetro non penso che lo spessore vetro
quel parito il baratro
il premio è uno specchio aveva tanti gli
sfigati cose cioè fumavano si riscatta
al bene perché ancora gatti che è bello
come si è rotto forme ma almeno con
questo lo sapevi solo gli dicevano stato
non sapevi tu come cazzo hai fatto a
saperlo
c'è una stanza dietro il vetro costa
come come possibile c'è il liceo anche
se non l'ho fatto perché anche se non
però il m dicevo ma che cazzo igieniche
caserme ciononostante dietro cosa chiede
una stanza dietro i vetri
comunque questi sono gli spiega 7 10 10
m prossimo dieci anni spiega grazie ma
ecco che senza di te sarei morto del
defunto
fotografico quel loss a voi christian
greiche sculaccia mattino oppure
occhio è rotondo mestre guardali
quarant'anni fa vj skillen tanta di
parigi skillato tornato andare dove devo
andare
ha tirato una testata il coni del
consiglio in più non serve a basic ha
mai preso metto collezionabili in mezzo
a tutto ciò già tanto se finisco in
gioco cazzate ma che volete accendere
lega ma che c'hai n'a siga avete st
pagnottella arrivano a mazzetta da sotto
i denti
il corso è questo che cazzo e saw
l'enigmista con gli occhi storpi la
regala il call center all ospedale gli
altri marco degli obesi
la carica dei 101 pesi esatto arca
[ __ ] non ci passò sotto 72 dio sa se
va bene a tutti i ragazzi un attimo è
cascato il comodino giorno lanceremo
madonna che anzi sto gioco ora quello
come contento ma mangiatevi tra di voi
schifosi signora ma pensate cosa
uno è morto al vostro posto grazie
questo è vedi il cappello di indiana
jones ha subito dopo da mettere a terra
grazie a tutti messo anni passati a
giocare ai videogiochi c'è poi la parte
di pila ci ho messo un'ora e mezza
questa gara difficile che ho fatta
subito
abbiamo passato il ristorante abbiamo
passato le dispense abbiamo passato
tutto e questo ha fame
adesso adesso sono pagati addosso
ripagarti addosso
[Musica]
io te lo dicevo dall'inizio del gioco in
questi scommetti che sono magna a lui ma
è volevi così si va così così si va si
fa così si fa così
cosi luisa mi ha capito tutto
tutto ha capito a vista la nutella è
[Musica]
credibile ci voglio credere
ho mangiato nano è stato bellissimo
poter incassare ma chi sta tizia
se non è un nemico
devo capire un andare da scusate
semplicemente cliccando che hanno capito
capito devo prendere il bel barattolo da
contendenti harlow sul fai da te ga
fortissimo welcome problema lebron james
anaya verrà magic johnson attenzione
alla buon'ora è la bonolis ce l'ha c'è
quella che vuoi accendere una sigaretta
no perché quella di prima comunque
questa dati la zona ospiti
abbiamo passato dato paragrafo nice che
l'ultimo ora quindi è la sua pensione se
c'era un messaggio con l'altra volta che
un impiego di a questo in teoria
dovrebbe essere produttivo mentre dio e
non lo so
era un 45 di gioco quindi in teoria
dovrebbe sempre più bello non so se
dipende da quanto dura si è chiuso
ma da oggi del gioco nel ladakh come si
sente bene perché qua si sente
pianissimo un ticchettio non so se lo
sentono gli altri tipo di base come la
sentiresti che ti ho ragazzi questo è
solo e di mista questa è la morte che
viene a prenderci qualche dei quadri
miley cyrus
c'è la tipa che canta zio oddio
vedi anche lei la spiga ha rotto lo
specchio
aspettando si sta svecchiando su uno
specchio rotto quindi sono sono sempre
lì
[Musica]
non so se la tipa incazzata o meno
quindi dubbio faccio piano la chiamo
oggi a cena si no
[Musica]
ma devo chiamare fatto la [ __ ] scusa
fuma fumo grazie capito come scusa case
ridotte al merlino berlino niente niente
tipa che canta pazienza va beh
[ __ ] pensavo fosse gentile almeno una
anche se dal vetro rotto effettivamente
non è che poteva sparare su questa
quindi non devi proprio alle al tar la
perché come ti vede da massa sulla donna
tra i poteri questa
facevano st cantilena tutto il giorno in
testa
[Musica]
ci vorrà un per il piatto è il vaso
strumenti che la chiave là dentro
so che come era un po il vaso devo
fidarmi sotto il letto e sono una tipa i
fan culo coesivo vedere sapevo io non
sapevo cosa perché da troppi giochi la
mia vita
no
ha smesso di cantare
le canzoni
qualche brutto il quadro samara
i contenzioni chicca stata per la
[ __ ] di 4 nov il [ __ ]
roma si chiama roba grazie e rob
tu sei rom dice che secondo lui non
dovresti farti capelli hanno voluto bene
in questo modo grazie ti la mia mamma
roba della mia mamma chiara un momento
desse ai terribile
[Musica]
io non ho capiti scusami ma mi sono
messo sotto letto ma la tipa è sparita e
basta
anche bossi verso in un'altra stanza no
voglio fare domanda andiamo giù i quadri
sono veramente i più brutti che per
questo qua con la tuta a destra sembra
quella del di the house gioco avevo
giocato horror flash
voi ragazzi lo ricorderete perché vi
siete per iscritti che seguite le live è
che kakà assurda e donazioni nel momento
giusto ma lui ha due lo sarebbe
aspettato
così lo sapevo vengono fatte apposta ma
è una merda chiuso la porta a michael
accendino scusate io
e niente harry potter
poi la daranno precisa che se se ti
perdi un secondo e non corri subito cioè
nel culo ma devi può avere riflessi
prontissimi
fantastico dicevo io credo che il
che il tipo che sono un uomo di 30 anni
perché ci aveva l'accendino al caso
ciancimino una bambina
cosa vi serve ma da come si lamenta
questa non è un orgasmo serio da un bel
po e non lo trovi l'uomo giusto e vero
zia
te lo meriti anche comunque prima ha
usato i poteri cioè i poteri baba bubble
ball funzionano solo a distanza di un
metro perché oltre un metro non funziona
non mi prende nutro m deve correre
pagana geisha
quando una galassia
ma lei è la capa cerca c'è il capo della
nave insomma sembra sicuramente sarà il
capo ce la fai a passare minchia a devo
togliere le pratiche sorry sorry ok
cos'è sta roba qua tutti la tipa non può
specchiarsi perché gli specchi sono
tutti i lotti perché la tipa non può
specchiarsi quindi lo specchio è un arma
di difesa ho capito subito da bambini
tante sempre rotta iniziare un po lo
specchio sono il culo pregano ciao zia
sono specchio io c'ho lo specchio cioè
ne curò madonna patricia è sparita
specchio stata cliccata incredibile
e allora siccome faccio che ne so se mi
arriva dietro a devo andare nei posti
luminose o nei prossimi minuti
certo non ha fatto ripartire di cosa poi
bello che lui riparte in un angolino si
sveglia lei
la memoria back adesso specchio e si è
prodotta senza make up culona devo stare
nella luce scommette sul chiaro beni che
se in città sono cessa cioè ho capito si
mettono l'assassino è colpa mia
e dov'è di qua e compare a caso ok per
caso dove succhiato ma il boss finale
tipo perché è un vero scontro questa può
essere posto in al giorno ma si aspetta
che che non posso leggere
amica mi fa anche le finte adesso sei
quadrato succhia quanto comprerà fare
sta roba che c'è l'ansia mille che stavi
spunta non mi fa la vita patate poi
punta sfida tra partiti e fatto bene sto
gioco è morta in quattro
questo grazie a qua un grandissimo ma
quanto dura questa vai combatte ma basta
a proprio no se uno specchio
[Musica]
e morta grande beh sì che la mazzetta da
sottili e noi ha fame non c'è parola
maggio lei
l'omaggio lei dare gambe a nutella dopo
la fame
mi chiamo cioè fammi un classico maggio
tutti tutti 6 mag era come un automa mai
omaggio anche te ti usa come
stuzzicadenti che ti divora la famiglia
che divora tutto arrivo da metto bel
faccino c'è un po di condimento cioè la
panna e private non trovare mai comprato
un tranquillo la madonna vampiro
il potere
dell'olio che niente
è in me
19 euro e 90 cena 9 euro e 90 a pranzo
mischia quanto incazzata scusa ma
cos'era era un bambino io mai finito
sino a fini tosi
cioè io ho mangiato una tizia vera
grossa più grossa porca [ __ ]
potete aspetta che sta che sta giocando
questa è bianco freezer
super stagliata ma si sa si era il
cappuccio della super sé
ciao zio
tutti i petali neri intorno ho visto un
sacco di film horror di bambine così
allora che si spengono le luci
sto camminando io adesso sto fermo non
cammina vita sento il potere della del
male che in me per l'agenzia perché
viene rovinato dal bello a tutti ragazzi
ciao ti succhio anche la famiglia e
conto in banca e continua anche è morto
nella famiglia ma ne frega niente
ciao zio per tutti i due che mi hai
messo a scuola lurida traiano hai messo
dislike al video per i tre cave da bravo
ciao papi gay fa schifo schifo jj fa
schifo poi j a bridgend fece cancro
ecco che anche tu
in campo
michele gara bellissima star scena
[Musica]
la distanza della signora rush e quindi
sulla carta
da sauro
[Musica]
sento gabbiani quindi stiamo uscendo sta
mandando all'aria bear all'aria aperta
quindi io sono diventato un demonio è
solo uscendo l'aria aperta e ma è
l'apocalisse un anno prima mazzo tutto
strage faccio uso
super super super super figo bellissimo
ma bellissimo il finale è stato
veramente film è piaciuta un sacco m'è
piaciuto stanza più figo che a me
l'aspettavo macchina e questi veramente
figo ci aveva fatto ragazzi questa è la
hit del nightmares bellissimo i giorni
non pensavo fosse così figo è mica
come la bella a tutti i ragazzi sotto
finissimo grazie raga di
di aver partecipato a queste due live
mega che abbiamo fatto solo l'inter
nightmares è stato troppo troppo troppo
figo
mi è piaciuto il proprio tanto è
piaciuto alla fine però
[Musica]
poi la musica di sto gioco mi sono
piaciuto un sacco non aver mai visto
veramente tanti
non ho capito se avessero diventato un
demonio non è più dura legge anche
legislative di al pianeta mai perché
gliene frega e non è tutto il caso però
tipo ci sono le spiegazioni di finale di
una spiegazione finale gli interventi
giuseppe fazio giuseppe fazio ha fatto
quel grazie giuseppe vegas e niente raga
mi affido l'inter nightmare stato molto
molto figo
ovviamente se non sa se non c'è lo
scarso e qui non c'è ormai basilare
allora lascio la lascio facciamo
lasciamo la vita ragazzi io ringrazio
mister ecco il messaggio più intere
nazioni
una dialettica lawrence non essere una
fan di olbia
volevo rifiutare lei e poi se coperte un
secondo e due amiche si chiamano silvi e
chiara ciao si piace alessia cerchiare
grazie mi seguite da via nice
poi giorgia katy ad ore e consiglia di
comprato un paio e cary crucci per che
saresti bellissimo poi non direi di
giorgia ma i problemi che cosa dei sogni
erotici fi
guardami vinci mancato con quello e poi
la mappa da ciò l'ora riparativa ancora
fare il video dei racconti è il tuo
primo iscritto ma già è vero sta ancora
aspettando della rara dei marini tra di
roma ormai ci vogliamo bene in internet
che a roma ma per la vicina mah na mah
na mah na grassi in avanti ma se non
basteranno
iscriviti grazie la meni in internet sia
quella prima new york 9 non dicono cosa
mi ha chiesto ancora iscritto
ma solo per gli ok ok lo faremo lo
faremo ragano faremo che devo spiegare
di ramirez più salute grazie grazie
ragazzi per aver partecipato a questa
live io direi che è stato veramente figo
ali del nike mag con figo
e durata un'ora e mezza se un paio d'ore
invece no non ero a metà gioco allora o
più avanti è durata molto meno di quanto
pensassi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto compiuto più l'episodio come
senso di avere un momento mi piace
ringrazio da teco che ha partecipato a
questa rai lascia anche il suo canale
inter description dopo aver hai
veramente e tre assi cosa mi piace il
momento mi piace anche perché di tutto
dal tiziana sociali fisiatri ci mettiamo
il prossimo video non soffrendo questa
volta faccio da cinque anni è l'unica
roba che faccio di movimento nel mio
lavoro e non lo so fare questo è un
problema
il live facciamo che giusto pina la juve
io faccio da quasi sto sincronizzati e
aperta 3 a 2 1